[Music]
and maybe I was 14 but was certainly
close to nage and there was this big
trend for an ordering I think you guys
call it singing telegrams right singing
telegram yeah someone comes through the
door and there was a cowboy or something
sings a song and so there was this kind
of big vote and they used to get this
free magazine on the tube that had lots
of lists of agencies for those and we
would order them for our friends
birthdays and we'd had like a little
friend it had a Tarzan and a gorilla and
things I thought wouldn't it be extra
funny if we got a fully stripped
stripping one a naked man cause it's do
me at that point there's nothing more
funny than a naked man which is an idea
I think a naked man is very funny but in
the real life often not as funny I hope
not yeah gonna be depressing it ya know
I don't like it when they find it
amusing what do people find me amusing
yes not many that's a terrible thing
women are like you know it's like a
religious experience what do you mean I
thought it might be funny so so we
called up stripping you go it's a vicar
here do you priest
freeze right I mean ripping priest it's
already better wait and his name was the
Reverend boss so anyway so it was quite
cheap it wasn't you know we could afford
is everything called up and of course
I'd call up in my 13 14 year old boys
hello you know we'd like to order the
Reverend balls please and nobody said
you sound a bit young for the Reverend
balls you know you can't have him so
they said all right what's the address
yeah and so it was my best friend's
birthday and there's about only about
five of us in the house and we didn't
have the music on it what rather sedate
five girls in the house and then instead
of a middle-aged quite unattractive
skinny bald ish bloke
turned up and said you do want the full
strip and of course immediately he said
that not funny at all Thursday imagining
this man is just horrifying it was
this is just wrong across the board Roy
yeah and you think when he came to the
door and saw us standing there he'd say
when I can't possibly be naked but he
did immediately offer the full strip and
then we said no god no please - yeah he
was really committed to the priests part
of it yeah you want the full strip yeah
you're looking to him to be the
responsible party here now I am is the
strip or the strange stripper who came
to the door I know and I'd sent my
mother off to get a pizza or something
so it was nobody there to rescue us and
then he came in and he started she sort
of took off he had one of those little
cockney odo collars on that Vickers have
on and and he suddenly flung everything
off of me standing there with with
everything kind of horribly stuffed into
this kind of elephant thong everything
is in the trunk
what a great fourteen-year-old birthday
party wait so what does your muds as
your mom show up no she didn't I did I
mean I didn't I hadn't told her about it
obviously I did I hadn't really thought
it you shouldn't tell anybody we're on
television right did you get him out of
there
well we can't think oh thank you so much
that was great and he said meet my
friend from the mission and went to get
the elephant off thank God we managed it
we obviously look suitably devastated
and we didn't get that get that off and
then he's and then he sort of tried to
get her half-heartedly tried to get
somebody to slap his bottom and then
wouldn't they because he couldn't find
one of his socks well he was there ages
it was very awesome yeah yeah he's
looking around the house for his song
and it's under collection now why would
you leave wait please when will the
Reverend balls leave close that donger
was he just in the elephant
[Music]
making the way I am did tell your
daughter this story you know she's seen
a photo of it
there's a photographic yesterday fit it
was too rude to show on your show so
didn't show that he's not rude first
show I've never been told that anything
was too rude for this is a new benchmark
for this show maybe this is more
upsetting than me I'm sure it's
upsetting yeah three recent Athan with
14 year old girls yeah maybe that's it
yeah get a photo yeah yeah yeah I can't
wait for that photo I don't know what
you talked about now you see that photo
seriously we're all kind of best boy
that would that would that would be a
bummer to see the girls but yeah you
just want to see the Reverend balls
absolutely that's the funny part